[Musik]
und jetzt das heute-journal
deutsch-französische solidarität mit der
ukraine emanuel makro und olaf scholz am
abend vor dem brandenburger tor
präsident und bundeskanzler haben sich
natürlich auch darüber ausgetauscht wie
putins auftritt heute in moskau zu
bewerten ist guten abend zum heute schon
ein dass eigentümlichste des heutigen
tages war vielleicht dass der kreml fast
eine art business as usual präsentation
seiner weltkriegs siegesparaden lieferte
es wurde jedenfalls kein krieg erklärt
schon gar kein dritter weltkrieg putin
haben das wort krieg noch nicht mal in
den mund und er rief auch nicht zu einer
landesweiten mobilmachung auf was manche
erwartet hatten genauso wenig erklärte
er irgendeinen aktuellen sieg was
faktisch auch schwerlich möglich wäre
aber fakten haben den kreml ja selten
von propaganda abgehalten andreas weise
über das was heute in moskau bekannt was
nicht geschah
es soll eine machtdemonstration seien
vom russischen staatsfernsehen
aufwendiger bildsprache präsentiert die
sieges parade auf dem roten platz
eigentlich also fast alles wie immer
aber nur fast zum einen fehlten
kampfjets die sonst zu diesem anlass
über das zentrum moskaus donnern das
wetter habe das nicht zugelassen so die
offizielle begründung zum anderen
warteten diesmal alle mit spannung auf
die traditionell recht kurze ansprache
des präsidenten
doch weder wurden weitere
eskalationsstufen erklommen noch
friedensangebote gemacht putin geht es
vor allem um die rechtfertigung des
überfalls auf das nachbarland
wir hatten gesehen wie eine militärische
infrastruktur entstand die hunderte
ausländische berater ihre arbeit
aufnahmen regelmäßige lieferungen
modernster waffen aus den nato-ländern
erfolgten die bedrohung mit jedem tag zu
russland hat der aggression eine
präventive abfuhr erteilt
quasi gefahr im verzug auch wenn das
durch nichts belegt ist ungewöhnlich die
zusagen großzügiger hilfen für die
hinterbliebenen in der ukraine
gefallener oder verwundeter soldaten
anlässlich dieser parade
der staat die regionen wie unternehmen
und gesellschaftlichen organisationen
werden alles tun um solche familien mit
fürsorge zu umgeben um ihnen zu helfen
besondere unterstützung werden wir den
kindern der gefallenen und verwundeten
kampfgefährten gewähren ein
präsidentenerlass ist dazu heute
unterzeichnet worden
offiziell wird derzeit von russischer
seite keine zahl von gefallenen genannt
doch die sorge scheint gross je mehr
särge aus der ukraine zurück kommen
desto unruhiger könnte es im volk werden
heute aber viel unterstützung für putin
und seinen kurs nach dem militär gehören
die straßen rund um den roten platz den
bürgern aus allen landesteilen sie
machen mit beim sogenannten
unsterblichen regiment zeigen bilder
gefallener aus jedem krieg seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg auch von soldaten die
in der ukraine starben und präsident
putin mitten unter ihnen zeigte er sich
in letzter zeit doch lieber an meter
langen tischen von gesprächspartnern
getrennt so scheint er jetzt den kontakt
zum volk zu suchen und viele folgen
seiner erzählung von sogenannten nazis
in der ukraine und dass der westen
russland attackieren wollen
wenn es da keine nazi regierung mehr
gibt wird es auch frieden geben
ich denke dass das alles von amerika
ausgeht dass die unser land in ihren
besitz bringen und all unsere
bodenschätze und reichtümer haben wollen
denn das was wir besitzen lockt sie sehr
zum beispiel das erdgas
ein tag des sieges mitten im krieg und
viele fragen bleiben offen
schalten wir erstmal nach moskau zu
unserem korrespondenten christiansen das
denn diese parade gibt es ja nun jedes
jahr aber in was für eine atmosphäre
hast du das diesmal erlebt
ja vielleicht putin hat sich die große
bühne hier selbst bereitet die
innenstadt abgesperrt überall wehende
fahnen und dann die große parade hier
auf dem roten platz hinter mir und auch
wenn man da jetzt nicht viel neues
erfahren hat in der rede ist wurde er
vorher spekuliert was er alles sagen
könnte ist es doch erstaunlich und es
zeigt auch wie wichtig das ist was putin
heute gesagt hat war mit einigen
menschen hier gesprochen und die
wiederholen doch gebetsmühlenartig was
putin auch eben als argumente
hervorgebracht hat warum diese spezielle
militäroperationen sein muss und das
zeigt einfach wie wichtig ist wie auch
die propaganda hier funktionierten sich
das in den köpfen der menschen festsetzt
kritische stimmen die haben wir hier
heute gar nicht gehört die sind ja im
prinzip komplett von der straße verbannt
worten das hat putin in den letzten
monaten und wochen geschaffen trotzdem
gab es eine kleine protestaktion heute
im satellitenfernsehen im russischen und
auch bei einem internetportal wurden
anti kriegs botschaften verbreitet also
so ganz wollen die kritischen stimmen
dann doch nicht verschwinden
danke dir für diese einschätzung nach
moskau diese eindrücke
derweil hat sich heute auch der
ukrainische präsident geäußert selensky
erinnerte an den zweiten weltkrieg und
sagte wir haben damals gewonnen wir
werden auch diesmal gewinnen und fügte
hinzu schon bald würden in der ukraine
zwei tage
quasi dance events gemacht der
eigentlich für eigene bevölkerung mit
katrin eigendorf in kiew die wurde dann
der auftritt putins in der ukraine ja
wahrgenommen eingeschätzt
ja hier in kiew war es eigentlich ein
gespenstisch still am abend heute es hat
wieder flug alarm gegeben
die menschen hier haben doch angst vor
weiteren angriffen auch auf die
hauptstadt kiew davor war ja immer
wieder gewarnt worden aber die rede
putins hat hier nicht wirklich für
erstaunen gesorgt die menschen mit denen
wir hier heute gesprochen haben die
haben eigentlich alle übereinstimmend
gesagt das sind die gleichen alten lügen
die wir jetzt schon seit wochen hören da
ist ja nichts neues passiert und auch
die politischen kommentatoren haben
eigentlich er diese rede als schwäche
putins inter frittiert und haben gesagt
es fehlt völlig division putin erzählt
immer wieder das gleiche narrativ von
der faschisten regierung die er hier
entmachten will die ganze welt weiß dass
es sich hier um eine lüge handelt und
sagen wir mal die ideologische
eskalation mit der man hier gerechnet
hat dass er sein eigenes volk noch
einmal weiter gegen die ukraine auf
bringt diesen krieg noch einmal deutlich
eskaliert das ist ja ausgeblieben und
auch das haben die argumente haben die
kommentatoren als schwäche gewertet man
hat hier ganz genau hingeguckt wird
dieser tag in moskau inszeniert und was
zum beispiel sofort eine meldung wert
war war die tatsache dass überall im
land ja die flugschauen abgesagt wurden
angeblich wegen des wetters da waren die
kommentatoren sich sofort einig dass das
ja nur auch wieder eine weitere lüge ist
und dass auch dies wahrscheinlich ein
zeichen der schwäche ist und man fragte
sich ja hat putin vielleicht überhaupt
noch genug flugzeuge zur verfügung um
das so zu inszenieren das ist der tag
hier in der ukraine gewesen aber
natürlich überwiegt bei den menschen
hier die angst davor dies dass dieser
krieg weiter in extremer brutalität
geführt wird denn es gab ja aus moskau
überhaupt gar kein anzeichen dafür dass
man in irgendeiner form hier auf die
ukraine zu gehen will sondern der krieg
geht weiter dankeschön katrin diese
einschätzung zu ihren eindrücken in kiew
befragt wie sie nachher im heute-journal
update auch noch bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas die heute von ihrem ukraine
besuch zurückgekehrt ist
ja wie katrin eigendorf eben sagte der
krieg geht weiter
es wird weiter bombardiert und
verschleppt gekämpft und gestorben
russland und die ukraine militärisch
stehen an diesem tag der erinnerung an
vergangene siege dazu gleich noch ein
gespräch mit ex general ramms zuvor
zeichnet yasin herlein ein bild der
aktuellen lage
auch in mario pohl der zerstörten
geschundenen stadt wurde von einigen
heute der sieg des neunten mai gefeiert
von angehörigen der russischen
minderheit in der ost ukraine
zunächst haben die behörden es nicht
erlaubt aber jede familie hat diesen
feiertag doch begann
das bürgermeister amt hat uns genehmigt
dass wir blumen niederlegen seit 2014
ist uns klar dass wir wieder mit
russland vereint sein werden
auf den osten der ukraine den teil des
landes mit dem größten
russischsprachigen bevölkerungsteil
hatten sich ja zuletzt die militärischen
aktionen der russischen armee
konzentriert doch seit tagen ist der
frontverlauf weiter weitgehend
unverändert schwere kämpfe gibt es nach
wie vor um mario pohl und das dortige
stahlwerk diese bilder zeigen schwere
einschläge die gestern von dort
evakuierten zivilisten kamen heute in
einem nachbarort an
das größte problem war an brennholz und
an essen heranzukommen um die menschen
satt zu kriegen ohne verletzt zu werden
denn ich musste dies tun während wir
bombardiert wurden
gekämpft wird auch im dom bass und
städte wie kramer chost sind die
zerstörungen massiv um ein geschlossenes
band im osten und süden und den zugang
zum schwarzen meer zu kontrollieren
müsste die russische armee odessa
einnehmen heute wurde die millionenstadt
von raketen getroffen
eu-ratspräsident michelle der sich zu
gesprächen dort aufhielt musste in
sicherheit gebracht werden
ich meine es ist es zugeschaltet general
idea des heeres der bundeswehr und er
war einer der höchsten nato generäle im
namen terra
männer und frauen können sie haben sich
die rede von putin und den ganzen
auftritt dieser parade heute natürlich
auch angesehen was haben sie davon für
einen eindruck mitgenommen
ja das war eine veranstaltung heute bin
ich die mit folie und siegesparaden zum
neunten mal vergleichen dann würde ich
sagen sie hat mit gebremstem schaum
stattgefunden und bei der rede von putin
fand ich interessant dass er versucht
hat die brücke zu knüpfen von den
veteranen die den sieg über nazi
deutschland errungen haben zu den
kämpfern die heute im don boscos weise
in der ukraine kämpfen
hat damit eine versuchte eine
gemeinsamkeit zu beschwören und
möglicherweise die soldaten die im
donbass eingesetzt sind auf diese art
und weise auch entsprechend zu
motivieren
doch seit bei solchen paraden ist aus
sicht eines militärs ja auch was da so
wie die straße rollt oder was davor
geführt wird und sagen manche wir haben
da in den letzten jahren so manches
vorgeführt bekommen was bombastisch
aussah aber was auf den schlachtfeldern
gar nicht zu sehen ist bestimmte panzer
typen zb werden da zum teil auch
potemkin staffa präsentiert
also mit dem begriff botanisches dorf
wäre ich vorsichtig aber sie haben recht
mit der feststellung dass beispielsweise
der modernsten kampfpanzer russlands der
tvc hertha ist ja auf den
schlachtfeldern ukraine nicht
aufgetaucht ist was ein vorteil
sicherlich auch für die ukraine ist
keine frage wovon aber möglicherweise
auch bisher nur so geringe stückzahlen
produziert worden sind dass es keinen
sinn macht diese branche einzusetzen sie
befinden sich im westlichen
militärbezirks sie gehören
beispielsweise zur ersten garde
panzerarmee dann reden wir über sankt
petersburg und ich glaube nicht dass
putin diese westflanke für ihn oder
nordwest flanke für ihn von militärs von
schwerem gerät befreien wird weil er ja
der phobie lebt in der nato phobie lebt
dass die leute ihn angreifen könnte was
ja aufgrund der geschichte der nato
eindeutig widerlegt ist was heute auch
diskutiert wurde haben es eben gehört
dass in der ukraine auch für besondere
aufmerksamkeit sorgte dass diese
flugzeuge obwohl diese eifrig geübt
hatten und wohl auch ein großes zetteln
himmel schreiben sollten also dass diese
kampfflieger heute über moskau nicht
gestartet sind gibt es aus militärischer
sicht eine eine plausible erklärung oder
kann man da nur spekulieren
also man kann eigentlich nur spekulieren
darüber
das java verschiedene sieges beraten
diese flugeinlagen geben sollte nicht
nur in moskau und wenn dann die gesamte
luftwaffe nicht in die luft kommt dann
ist irgendwas nicht in ordnung das kann
auch dann aufgrund der unterschiedlichen
wetterlagen in verschiedenen bereichen
nicht nur am wetter gelegen haben da
können elektronische sachen gründe wohl
eine rolle spielen da können
einsatzbereitschaft eine rolle spielen
auf jeden fall ist dieses ein punkt den
man noch mal sorgfältig auswerten sollte
und ich bin davon überzeugt dass die
geheimdienste der amerikaner und die
briten dieses in den nächsten tagen
machen würden man fragt sich ja sowieso
wie es um die flug kraft der russen
stellt es ist erstaunlich dass die
ukraine hat man noch fliegen und das die
russen bislang bei weitem nicht die
wirkliche lufthoheit erreicht haben wenn
man das so laienhaft sagen dafür über
der ukraine oder wie sehen sie das
also die russen sind in bestimmten
bereichen mit ihren luftstreitkräften
den ukrainern eindeutig überlegen aber
wenn wir beispielsweise runtergehen nach
süden also weiter weg von der russisch
ukrainischen grenze dann verändert sich
dieses verhältnis eindeutig von hat die
ich sag mal so viele einsätze der
ukraine im bereich der schlangen insel
gesehen das war schon zum teil
beeindruckend und wenn die ukraine dort
noch in dieser form fliegen können dann
sollte das auch dass sie offensichtlich
ihre technik im griff haben und dass sie
auch in der lage sind trotz angriffen
auf flughäfen und angriffen oder
flugzeuge die auf flughäfen stehen immer
noch teufel in die luft zu bringen aber
es wäre wahrscheinlich trotzdem ein
fehler die die russische feuerkraft und
lehrkraft zu unterschätzen und sich in
der hoffnung zu wiegen dass da steht
über kurz oder lang an sieg der ukraine
vor der tür oder wie schätzen sie das
ein
also über kurz oder lang dann schon eher
lang das wird noch eine erhebliche zeit
in anspruch nehmen in dieser beziehung
ist die ukraine auch abhängig von den
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen weil
sie selber nicht genügend schweres gerät
hat um entspricht und ich sag mal
angriffs weise gegen die russen in den
bereichen die russen besetzt haben
vorzugehen das macht die sache dann
schon relativ schwierig und das spricht
eher dafür dass diese auseinandersetzung
noch eine erhebliche lange zeit dauern
wird eine weitere anmerkung zu dem thema
ist das offensichtlich ich sag das mal
von nachrichtendiensten im westen aber
auch von uns insgesamt die schlagkraft
der russischen streitkräfte deutlich
überschätzt worden ist
das zeigte sich auch in den kämpfen und
ihr von den handlungen die dann
hinterher gefolgt sind das allein die
kampfmoral der ukrainische streitkräfte
in der lage war die angeblich überlegen
die russische technik aufzuhalten
herangehens das gespräch
herzlichen dank gerne
prozent steht einerseits da wenn zwar
nicht wie ein kaiser ohne kleider aber
so doch ein damit irgendwie beschränkter
garderobe andererseits gab er wilde
verschwörungstheorien von sich und
bezeichnete dieses verhältnis zwischen
nato und kleine und ihnen eigentlich in
einer form klassischer täter opfer
umkehr wie man im politischen berlin und
anderen hauptstädten auf die punkte rede
heute reagiert wurde das fast jetzt
andreas cüppers zusammen
sie nehmen den ordner und dann können
sie hier ganz normal ihr leben das
schiff das ist ein kampf um symbole an
diesem 9 mai in berlin und er wird
unerbittlich geführt um das st georgs
bank zum beispiel jenes russische
militär abzeichen das heute verboten ist
am sowjetischen ehrenmal in
berlin-treptow aber nicht jedem verboten
werden kann man hat russlands
botschafter in deutschland seit wochen
nicht gesehen und so noch nie es ist ein
kampf um symbole an diesem 9 mai an dem
die erste auslandsreise frankreichs
wiedergewählten präsidenten auf die
terrasse des bundeskanzleramtes führt
makro und scholz geben die antwort auf
die rede des russischen präsidenten in
berlin und gemeinsam das
kabinett dem 8 ich denke dass es heute
keine weitere eskalation graf keine
verbale eskalation keine geografische
eskalation aber auch keine eskalation
durch die verwendung von waffen ist das
ausreichend oder zufriedenstellend nein
denn was wir erreichen wollen ist eine
waffenruhe
was russland erreichen will stellt
seinen botschafter klar 77 jahre nach
dem ende des nationalsozialismus soll
mit der ukraine das nächste land
entnazifiziert werden kriegspropaganda
am anti kriegs denkmal
ratifiziert wird ganz nicht
meinen sie das nicht gelingt
[Musik]
deinen frieden ohne das ist die ukraine
als nazi land wie einst nazi-deutschland
für viele unerträglich ich möchte das
gar nicht kommentieren weil das so
falsch ist wir haben wirklich allen
gedacht und wenn ich sehe dass menschen
holocaust-überlebende durch angriffe der
russen gestorben sind halte ich das für
ein wirklich perfektes beispiel einer
bestimmten propaganda die durchgesetzt
werden soll es ist ein kampf um symbole
an diesem 9 er wird stumm und hilflos
geführt in berlin und laut und voller
wut in warschau russlands botschafter in
polen mit roter farbe attackiert als
mörder mörder beschimpft und an der
kranzniederlegung gehindert
makro und scholz versuchen in berlin den
eindruck zu zerstreuen das deutschland
der ukraine weniger entschlossen hilft
als andere staaten
wenn sie sehen dass die politik von
deutschland frankreich italien spanien
großbritannien und den usa sich nicht
unterscheiden sondern dass die komplett
identisch sind in der frage was wir
machen und auf welche weise wird diese
hilfe zur verfügung stellen es ist ein
kampf der symbole am tag der
militärparade in moskau ein
abendspaziergang in berlin putin auf dem
roten platz kanzler und präsident auf
dem blau-gelben
zu den mutmasslich ungewollten
nebenwirkungen der putin schon invasion
gehört dass sich schweden und finnland
aller voraussicht nach auf den weg in
die nato machen und die ukraine noch
drängender an die tür der eu klopft als
zuvor mit dem thema beginnt die
nachrichten es geht zunächst um die
frage ob die ukraine wie gewünscht
offiziell eu beitrittskandidat werden
kann dazu will die eu-kommission laut
präsidentin von der leyen
voraussichtlich noch im juni eine
stellungnahme abgeben
frankreichs präsident marc reinhardt
hoffnungen auf einen schnellen
eu-beitritt gedämpft das verfahren könne
jahrzehnte dauern er schlug stattdessen
eine europäische politische gemeinschaft
mit neuen formen der zusammenarbeit vor
die bundesregierung zeigt sich
zuversichtlich die raffinerie im
brandenburgischen schwedt mit rund 1200
beschäftigten erhalten zu können trotz
des geplanten öl-embargo der eu gegen
russland bundeswirtschaftsminister
habeck sagte heute bei einem besuch der
raffinerie die vorbereitungen für neue
ölquellen über schiffe via rostock sowie
die finanzierung von verlusten und eine
mögliche treuhand struktur liefen
bereits wenn alles drei klappe hätten
die beschäftigten jobsicherheit für die
nächste zeit
die bundesregierung hat eine serie von
cyber angriffen auf deutsche behörden
und ministerien in den vergangenen tagen
bestätigt die angriffe seien simpel
strukturiert gewesen und hätten
abgewehrt werden können daten wurden
demnach nicht gestohlen eine russische
hacker gruppe bekannte sich zu den
attacken
nach der landtagswahl in schleswig
holstein hat sich ministerpräsident
günther auch heute bedeckt gehalten mit
wem er die nächste regierung bilden will
er sagte habe sowohl die grünen als auch
die fdp zu gesprächen eingeladen und
kündigte sondierungsgespräche für
dienstag nächster woche an laut
vorläufigen amtlichen endergebnis liegt
die cdu deutlich zu und kommt auf 43,4
prozent die grünen werden zweitstärkste
kraft erreichen 18,3 prozent die spd
schafft nur noch 16 die fdp 6,4 prozent
der südschleswigsche wählerverband legt
zu und kommt auf
5,7 prozent die afg ist mit 4 4 prozent
nicht im landtag
bei der präsidentenwahl auf den
philippinen liegt nach ersten berichten
der sohn des ehemaligen diktators
ferdinand marcos klar vorne demnach
könnte fast 40 jahre nach absetzung
seines vaters nun ferdinand marcos
junior staatsoberhaupt werden der
bisherige präsident tut rte durfte nicht
für eine weitere amtszeit antreten
in sri lanka ist nach landesweiten
demonstrationen ministerpräsident
rajapakse zurückgetreten er wolle damit
so hieß es den weg für eine
alleinregierung freimachen vor der
rücktrittsankündigung hatte es
gewaltsame zusammenstöße zwischen
regierungsgegnern und befürwortern
gegeben laut polizei wurden mindestens
130 menschen verletzt sri lanka steckt
in einer wirtschaftskrise es fehlt an
treibstoff lebensmitteln und
medikamenten
noch leben wir ja in einem zeitalter in
dem es immer wieder heißt dass diese
oder jene position erstmals an eine frau
geht naja so wird immerhin jedes mal
bewusst dass das ein erstmals ist etwa
beim deutschen gewerkschaftsbund
an der spitze des dachverbands sind dem
rund 5,7 millionen mitglieder
organisiert sind steht von heute an die
spd-politikerin jasmine v über ihre wahl
berichten andrea support und lassen
wohl wahr frauen die gibt es hier und
seit heute auch an der spitze des dgb
jasmin fach chemie es die neue
vorsitzende nach über 70 jahren wird
erstmals eine frau oberste
gewerkschafterin in deutschland die
gleichberechtigung hat sie sich auf die
fahnen geschrieben deswegen weg mit der
sachgrundlosen befristung den minijobs
sind teilzeit fallen weg mit dem
paragraphen 219 a und keine milde bei
gewalt gegen frauen in diesem land wir
wollen brot und rosen kolleginnen die
passende dna die hat die kollegin
familie sie kommt von der ig bergbau
chemie und energie wechselt dann in die
politik wird spd generalsekretärin
bundestagsabgeordnete und
staatssekretärin im arbeitsministerium
jetzt der weg zurück in den schoß der
gewerkschaften nicht alle mitglieder
waren damit einverstanden auch wenn das
jetzt keiner mehr zu geben will die
hälfte aller beschäftigten sind weiblich
und deswegen tut es gut wird an der
spitze des deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes
eine frau steht familie übernimmt den
dgb in schwierigen zeiten nach zwei
jahren pandemie gefährdet die jetzt der
ukraine krieg wohlstand und
arbeitsplätze in deutschland
geworden die chemische industrie
stillsteht gibt es weder für die
pharmazeutische industrie noch für die
landwirtschaft ammoniak es gibt keine
hightech kunststoffe und lager für
windkrafträder keine batterien für
elektroautos und keine dämmstoffe für
die energetische gebäudesanierung
die gewerkschaften verstehen sich
traditionell als teil der
friedensbewegung trotzdem sagen sie ja
zu waffenlieferungen und befürworten
auch die 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
allerdings was nicht sein kann ist das
ist ein freibrief gibt auf der anderen
seite eben investitionsmittel nachher
fehlen den sozialen zusammenhalt und da
ist es etwas was wir unbedingt
garantieren müssen eine klare ansage an
die ampel koalition und an den spd
kanzler der verspricht vor dem dgb
kongress trotz hoher rüstungsausgaben
werde es keine sozialkürzungen geben wir
werden die projekte die wir für den
transformationen für die neue ausrüstung
unserer wirtschaft aber auch für den
sozialen zusammenhalt in deutschland uns
fest vorgenommen haben nicht einstellen
sie werden jetzt erst recht nötig seien
erst recht nötig ist für die
gewerkschaften übrigens ein kräftiger
schluck aus der lohnpulle die inflation
die hohen energie und lebensmittelpreise
muss durch steigende gehälter
ausgeglichen werden die preise steigen
enorm und gerade für menschen mit
normalen und eher gering einkommen ist
das extrem belastend und von da ist
unser anspruch und unser ziel in allen
tarifrunden die jetzt stattfinden und in
der nächsten zeit stattfinden diese
preissteigerungsrate auszugleichen krieg
klimakrise inflation umbau der
arbeitswelt ordentlich dicke bretter zu
bohren sind für die erste frau an der
spitze des dgb und
jetzt nochmal heinz auch mit wirtschaft
für unternehmen die von folgendes
ukraine krieges betroffen sind hat die
bundesregierung ein hilfspaket
vorgesehen dazu gehört auch ein
sonderkreditprogramm das heute anlaufen
soll valerie haller für wen gibt es da
welche unterstützung ja um 1 mal vorweg
zu schicken viele deutsche unternehmen
spüren ja den krieg in der ukraine in
einer situation in der viele wegen der
korona pandemie schon keine dicken
finanzpolster mehr haben und die kfw
will nun mit günstigen krediten helfen
unternehmen aller größen und branchen
entscheidend ist dass sie nachweisen
können wie sie konkret wirtschaftlich
von den sanktionen gegen russland oder
dem krieg in der ukraine betroffen sind
einen kredit kann erhalten dem
beispielsweise absatzmärkte weggebrochen
sind schaden entstanden ist durch
geschlossene fabriken vor ort oder weil
rohstoffe oder vorprodukte fehlen und
schließlich falls besonders hohe
energiekosten das geschäft stark
belasten vorgesehen sind in der regel
summen von bis zu 100 millionen euro das
geld bekommen sie über ihre hausbank das
ausfallrisiko liegt überwiegend beim
start dafür sind bis jahresende 7
milliarden euro im topf damit verbunden
die hoffnung die folgen des krieges für
die deutsche wirtschaft wenigstens etwas
abzufedern doch anders als die üppigen
corona hilfen fällt dieses paket dann
doch deutlich kleiner aus und ist er als
stoßdämpfer gedacht sorgen um die
konjunktur treiben auch aktienanleger um
der dax heute deutlich im minus was vor
allem darf dann liegt das chinas
konjunktur schwächelt das sind keine
guten vorzeichen für die deutsche
wirtschaft deren wichtigster
handelspartner nunmal china ist valerie
haller vielen dank
in der formel 1 hat max verstappen den
großen preis von miami gewonnen vor
schale claire und carlos sainz erstatten
verkürzte mit diesem sieg bei der
premiere in miami den rückstand auf den
in der gesamtwertung für und den schaden
erklärt um 2 auf 19 punkte pech hatte
mit schumacher der kurz vor schluss auf
platz neun liegend mit sebastian vettel
kollidierte und erneut ohne punkte blieb
das was man uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht es im zdf montagskino weiter oder
um 0 uhr gibt es dann unsere heute
schneider update mit wulf schmiese bis
morgen auf wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend für ein kurzes
frühsommerliches internets so reicht es
dass dieses hoch wolf über uns
hinweggezogen ist und nun weiter
richtung süden zieht es wird erstmal
deutlich milder wir erwarten bis zu 30
grad am mittwoch auch wenn die wärme
nicht alle trifft sie sehen hier ziehen
auch einige regenwolken morgen über den
norden deutschlands
es wird also erstmal sehr mild und das
merken wir auch nachts da sinken die
temperaturen in der west hälfte nämlich
nicht unter 14 bis 10 grad das ist schon
sehr mild zum teil hatten wir ja diese
nacht im norden noch frost kühler wird
dagegen im osten und im süden bei 9 bis
4 grad die letzten regenschauer und
gewitter fallen jetzt gerade in sich
zusammen und dann bildet sich hier auch
mal etwas nebel häufig ist die nacht
aber klar und von nordwesten kommen
dichtere wolken heran diese dichteren
wolken bringen danach etwas regen mit
schon tagsüber in schleswig holstein die
meisten von uns können sich aber auf
einen sehr freundlichen dienstag
einstellen mit sonne und wolken im
wechsel bei südwesten das ist keine gute
nachricht für den nordosten deutschlands
dann da herrscht zurzeit eine extreme
waldbrandgefahr stufe 5 von 5 ist
erreicht die im südlichen brandenburg
und auch an der elbe gemäss temperaturen
morgen liegen an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee bei 20 bis 22 grad 22 bis 23
grad sind es auch vom thüringer wald bis
zum alpenrand sonst gibt's
frühsommerliche 24 bis 28 grad und dann
wird es von tag zu tag kühler am samstag
sind es noch 15 bis 24 grad aber erst
mal wird der heißeste tag der mittwoch
seien mit bis zu 30 grad zum beispiel am
neckar guten abend